[MUSIC PLAYING]
KERRY MAGRO: It's an honor to
be here at the Google Cambridge
office.
This is a topic that's very
near and dear to my heart.
Growing up as a
nonverbal child--
I was actually nonverbal
till I was 2 and 1/2
and diagnosed with
something called
pervasive developmental disorder
not otherwise specified,
a form of an autism
spectrum disorder, when
I was four years old.
And I want to take a minute
today and really imagine--
imagine just starting off
with a potential employment
opportunity.
And imagine not being able
to get over 1,000 jobs.
Imagine getting denied
over 1,000 times
for a meaningful employment.
Now, that's one of
the extreme cases.
But that's actually one of
the cases of a young man
I know who is on the
autism spectrum, who
has an accounting major,
who graduated college,
was not able to get
over 1,000 jobs.
And when I asked him
about why he thought
he wasn't getting those jobs,
it was insane to hear about some
of the things that were
going on, things such
as, oh, some companies
didn't necessarily
think that disclosure
was a good idea.
Some companies
didn't think that,
looking at the bottom line,
that reasonable accommodations
for me would be a
little bit outrageous.
And I'm happy to say he now
has a job today at Ford Motor
Company.
But it took a very,
very long time
for this man who grew up with
many challenges due to autism.
And this is actually
something I deal
with almost every single
day in our community.
Today, as a eight-year
professional speaker,
I travel the country talking
about autism inclusion
and trying to become the
best version of yourself.
So my presentation topic
today, the ROI benefits
of hiring people with autism
and other special needs
in the workplace--
some of the things
that you truly, truly
need to know about
our community,
and I'll share about this a
little bit later, but in terms
of the autism community, over
80% of adults in the United
States are currently
unemployed or underemployed.
And now I can say, based on
overcoming many obstacles,
through over five different
therapies for almost 15 years
of my life in occupational,
physical, speech, music,
and theater therapy, I've
been able to overcome
many of my obstacles
today to pursue a career
in professional speaking.
It's given me the
wonderful opportunity
to become an
international speaker.
I had the opportunity to
write two bestselling books,
focus on special need parenting.
The first book, "Defining
Autism From the Heart,"
focused on self-advocacy
skills for some of my mentees
who were trying to come
out about having an autism
diagnosis for the first time.
And a second book, called
"Autism and Falling in Love,"
focus on trying to help
individuals with special needs
try to find relationships
and love for the first time.
When I was 18, I had no
idea how to talk to women.
Pretty sure I still
don't know how
to talk to women,
for the most part.
But I wrote this book based
on 10 years of journal entries
to help some of
my mentees today.
In addition to that, we've
had the wonderful opportunity
to consult on several
major motion pictures
to bring a realistic
portrayal of disability
to our entertainment industry.
We have been blown away by
the amount of films today
that have been focused on
individuals with disabilities,
but also TV shows.
If anyone in here has seen
shows such as "The Good
Doctor" on ABC, which focuses
on a surgeon who has autism,
and "Atypical," which
focuses on an 18-year-old man
on the autism spectrum trying
to find love on Netflix.
In addition to that,
I hosted a TV show
called "The Different Is
Beautiful Show" for over two
years with the theme that normal
is truly just a dryer setting.
That was the main theme.
We brought in many people
impacted by diagnosis
to share their stories
with the world to hear.
And then, finally,
a nonprofit founder
who's had the wonderful--
I've had a wonderful
opportunity to give out
52 scholarships for
students with autism
to go to college in
the past six years.
So in addition to that, in
addition to those two books,
we were actually also
able to contribute
to another book called
"College for Students
with Disabilities--
We Do Belong," which focuses
on 17 stories of people
with disabilities who
successfully navigated pursuing
a post-secondary education.
So some of the things you need
to know about our community
today is that, in terms
of the disabled community,
we are the fastest growing
minority in the United States.
One in five Americans currently
today has a disability.
And we've had the
wonderful opportunity
to work with
countless individuals
doing coaching, mentoring,
and training services
for individuals
with special needs
as they transition to adulthood.
And one of the big topics
we talk about, simply
because of that, is employment.
This has given us
opportunity to work
with the Department
of Labor many times
on initiatives, such as the
Employer Assistant and Resource
Network on disability inclusion.
It's a mouthful, so
we call it EARN, which
helps employers
recruit, hire, retain,
and advance people
with disabilities.
One of the big things you need
to know about the unemployment
rate, unfortunately, for
those with disabilities today
is that people with disabilities
are, for the most part,
majorly unemployed.
I mean, the autism community
is one of the biggest signs,
but in terms of the
overall rate of individuals
with disabilities,
is just about 8.4%,
while people with
disabilities is 3.7%.
So when we go into
businesses, we've
had the wonderful opportunity to
work with some amazing, amazing
organizations.
We talk about these
main topics, but we talk
about so much more as well.
And one of the biggest
things we talk about
is that individuals
with disabilities
are more likely to
stay at a job longer,
reducing employee turnover.
This has been a study
that's been done almost
on an annual basis by the
Department of Labor that's
showing that people
with disabilities
are more committed to
staying at a company longer.
They're also, because
of the gratefulness
of having meaningful employment,
having lower absentee rates.
And in an environment
today where we're currently
so focused on philanthropy
in many of our businesses,
87% customers say
they prefer shopping
at stores and with companies
that hire employees
with disabilities.
And higher company
standing once,
if an employee leaves because of
the diversity that was offered,
they're more likely to
go onto any recruiter
websites and encourage
people to follow
that company because
of them hiring people
with disabilities.
And then finally, in terms
of reasonable accommodations
today, one of the biggest things
I get when I go into companies
is, how much will the
bottom line cost me
for hiring someone
with a disability based
on reasonable accommodations?
And I'm glad to
say today, and it's
something I spread so much
awareness about year-round,
is that's more than
half of accommodations
today are absolutely
free, which does nothing
to the bottom line.
So it's a nice
little perk there.
Just to give you a
little background
on my own personal story
growing up with autism,
I grew up wanting to
be the next Larry Bird,
and I have no vertical
leap for the life of me.
So that was kind
of a difficulty.
However, I really got involved
with sport management.
So one of my first internships
ever was CBS Sports.
And I majored at Seton Hall
University in sports management
and I was hoping to pursue a
career in the sports world.
Once graduating
from college, I had
offers to work with many
different sport-related
organizations in
my tri-state area.
And I really fell in
love with my mentees.
I came out for the first
time about having an autism
diagnosis because
today I'm considered
to have a, quote unquote,
"invisible" disability.
Many people I meet to this day
say, Kerry, you have autism?
You don't look like
you have autism.
And I'm like, oh, that's an
interesting way of putting it.
And I have to tell them
that I will always have
autism for the rest of my life.
But I truly fell in
love with mentoring kids
with disabilities as they
transition to adulthood.
So I pursued a career
in public speaking.
And one of the
biggest things we--
one of the biggest
reasons why we also
decided to do this change
was because we realized
that many, many individuals
with disabilities
were truly still not
being able to be engaged
with the world around them.
So I wanted to share with all
of you really quickly a video
where we're trying to make the
world that more inclusive place
for everyone to live.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Can you say Merry Christmas?
- Merry Christmas.
- I am a big, big
friend of Santa.
Me and Santa are BFFs.
We go way back.
And Santa told me,
Kerry, could you
dress up as Santa Claus,
because you understand
the needs of these kids, and
give them a holiday experience
they would never forget?
- Smile.
Give me [INAUDIBLE].
Big smile, big smile.
- That was different, I think.
- So when everything is done--
Growing up on the
autism spectrum,
I could never meet Santa
Claus in a big mall
with difficulties with bright
lights, with loud noises,
and not wanting to be
around a lot of people.
I started my nonprofit, KFM
Making a Difference, in 2011.
I wanted to be a role
model for these kids
by trying to help them
with something that I never
was able to [INAUDIBLE].
- Can you dance with Santa?
Yeah, there we go.
- We turn the music down.
We turn the lights down, in
all the rooms for any kids who
are affected by bright lights.
And many of our elves are
special education teachers
and therapists who
truly understand
the needs of these kids.
- Woo!
- Yay.
We were three years
trying to do this.
And every year,
he's either crying
and he doesn't want to do it.
So this year, he made it.
Actually, he made it.
- You are an amazing mother.
[INAUDIBLE] is so lucky
to have you in his life,
and he always will be.
- I was actually nonverbal
till I was 2 and 1/2 years old.
And I remember when
the flash did go off,
I would literally just
start poking my mom and dad,
and not having the words to
say it, feeling overwhelmed.
Year after year,
now we're seeing
more and more of these
events sprang out
in local communities.
- We want to go see Santa.
- Let's go see Santa!
- Going to see Santa,
going to [INAUDIBLE]..
- Ho, ho, ho.
Merry Christmas
- Santa.
- Ryan.
Ryan, right?
- Christmas presents.
- Cheese.
Christmas presents.
- I actually only just
found out about this.
For years we just struggled.
It's the mall and the
noise and the line.
A lot of times, kids that
don't have visible challenges,
it's very difficult.
- Everyone say
Christmas presents.
- Christmas presents.
- We want to make sure
that these kids and these
communities understand the need
for us more sensory-friendly
events, that this needs
to be a national movement.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
KERRY MAGRO: So we
travel the country now,
and this was just one idea that
I had when four years ago, I
was just thinking about
how I can go about trying
to make more of a
difference in our community
and keep kids
engaged in the world.
But that Santa
event, which we've
had the wonderful
opportunity to have
over 500 children with
autism special needs
to meet Santa Claus
for the first time
in a sensory-friendly
setting, we were thinking
about our mentees a
lot at this time, too,
and how we could
go into businesses
and talk about hosting
sensory-friendly events
for maybe people who
are adults with autism
or other disabilities, to
make sure that they feel
included in the workplace.
We've talked to
many land developers
about things such as
the lights in some rooms
and how some individuals
with disabilities
might have things
such as sensory issues
where bright lights might cause
them a little bit of issues,
to even talking about
the size of walls,
to make environments a little
less loud for individuals
with special needs as well.
So we've started
talking about that
via a nonprofit organization
we started in 2011
called KFM Making a Difference.
At the same time, I was
pursuing my first year
as a professional speaker.
So now we go around to
countless businesses
and talk about the need
for more sensory-friendly
actual environments for
individuals with disabilities.
In addition to that, we've
had the wonderful opportunity
to give out a scholarship
for students with autism
to pursue a
post-secondary education,
where we now are able to
say that we've given out
over 52 scholarships
for students with autism
across the United States and
internationally to pursue
a post-secondary education.
And in addition to that,
the other big reason
why we do what we do
today is because we
understand that autism
and disability is
a life-long disorder.
So each one of
these individuals--
when I was growing up,
I had no peer mentoring.
And now I go into businesses
and I talk to them
about the importance of
peer mentors for anyone,
regardless if you're
just starting the job
or regardless if
you're non-disabled
because each and
every single one of us
need to think about
self-reflection at times
and what's going to be our
potential in the future.
It's so very, very important.
So I want to share
a story with you.
So over three years
ago, we started
a Facebook page called A Special
Community, where we highlight
people impacted by a diagnosis.
We now have over 120,000
Facebook followers, all
comprised of amazing, amazing
people from our community.
And every single
place we go speak
now, we bring a
tripod and a camera
and we highlight people
impacted by a diagnosis
to share their stories
with the world.
But we also start out each
interview with one question.
And it's, what would
you like for the world
to know about you?
And we met this
amazing kid named Liam.
He's 10 years old
from Minnesota.
And he said he wanted people
to know that sometimes,
because of autism,
it's sometimes
difficult to make friends.
And I wanted to share with you
his story really quickly today.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- So we're going to be
talking to the camera
and we want to make you famous.
So we literally want to make you
probably the most famous person
on the planet.
How's that sound?
- OK, OK.
- No pressure.
- Autism basically makes
it hard to connect.
It makes it hard to get that
connection, to make friends.
They feel like more loners
than, well, in groups.
It's also a learning disability.
And in some cases, it's hard--
you can't speak in some cases.
I met a kid called
Tom, who he has autism,
but he can't speak
in proper English.
He needs an iPad.
- So Liam, one
thing I want to know
is that I was actually diagnosed
with autism at an early age,
too.
And I don't know if I've
ever actually told you that.
But I want you to know
that I will always
be here to be your friend,
if you need a friend.
OK?
- Yeah.
- Because even though
it may be hard at times
to connect to other
people, I feel
like so many people
with autism like us just
want what anyone else
wants, to feel connected
and to have a friend.
So you've always got
a friend in me, OK?
Want to pound this out?
- Yeah.
Can you blow it up, too?
Oh, he blows it up.
You're awesome, Liam.
- I'm kind of tearing up.
Sorry.
- That's OK.
It's kind of emotional.
[END PLAYBACK]
KERRY MAGRO: So we've had
the wonderful opportunity
to meet with hundreds
and hundreds of kids
around the world, to
hear their stories.
But then we took a step forward.
After every single
video we've done,
we've done a
self-assessment to see
how we can go about
helping maximize anything
they mention in the video.
So one of the biggest
things with Liam
was he wanted to make friends.
So after that video
went viral on Facebook,
we started a Facebook group
for him called Liam's Buddies
where, moderated by
his mom, we would
have countless people
just saying that they
wanted to be Liam's friend.
That gave Liam the
courage to actually want
to pursue trying to make
more friends at his school.
And now I can say that he
has two really close friends
at his school today.
So we took this idea to start
just doing more and more
interviews, and this gave us an
idea to focus on how we can do
this to maximize employers'
understanding the world about
people with disabilities
and what they would like
for companies to know.
We've actually
started a video series
to highlight people
with disabilities.
To every single place we go,
we try to share at least one
or two videos for people
to get the perspectives
of individuals, not
only with autism,
but a wide range
of disabilities.
So the individual right
here, his name is David.
And David is actually one of the
most amazing people I've ever
met in my entire life.
David is blind.
He has a very rare disease
where he actually went blind
at a very, very early age.
And during his accommodations
when he was growing up,
he had to learn how to use
a walking cane to get around
and he had to navigate
reasonable accommodations
once he transitioned
to adulthood.
And now, actually, today we met
him speaking at a Work Matters
summit at PNC Bank in
Pennsylvania, where
we tried to talk about
the ROI benefits of hiring
people with disabilities.
And this is what David wanted
to share with the world.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The greatest
challenge was being
afraid to admit that
I was going blind.
I was afraid to use a white
cane to travel independently.
And I did, you know--
and then once you
face your fears,
and you learn the skills,
strategies, and techniques
as well as a
positive philosophy,
understanding and
believing that it's
respectable to
have a disability,
and surrounding yourself
with other people who
are possibility thinkers,
and say, hey, I can do it.
You can, too.
And I think that's
one of the things
that I had to really
come to grips with.
And then once I
learned, once I really
believed that it was respectable
to have a disability, once I
learned to use
assistive technology,
once I learned to use a cane
to travel independently,
once I recognized and
embraced those things,
life got a whole lot better.
Privileged, Kerry, to serve
as the executive director
of the Department of
Labor and Industry's
Office of Vocation
and Rehabilitation.
And we're the lead agency
responsible for employment
and training for people with
disabilities in Pennsylvania.
We've worked with
over 70,000 people
and helped over 8,500
people with disabilities
find real jobs with real pay.
So we're here today to partner
with PNC and other community
advocates and partners
to shine a positive light
on the potential of
individuals with disabilities
and to help people
recognize and understand
and believe that people
with disabilities
are the most untapped talent
pool for employers to consider.
So that's why we're here is
to help spread the good word.
And [INAUDIBLE] don't confuse
a bad day with a bad life.
And I think that's--
everybody has bad days.
Everybody gets upset.
But I think that's really it.
You've got to-- don't
just go through it
you've got to grow through it.
Sorry.
So I think that's
really important.
Don't confuse a bad
day with a bad life.
That's really, really important.
There's going to be good
days, there's going to be ups,
there's going to be downs.
Some days you're the statue and
some days you're the pigeon.
And so just knowing that
there are people out there who
want to see you succeed.
- Can I just say really
quickly on camera--
I want to jump right back in.
- Yeah.
- I think what you're doing,
we need more people such as you
who just don't let
anything get in their way.
Because I know I won't let
anything get in my way.
And I know that
you'll do the same.
- I appreciate that, Kerry.
We need more people who are
just possibility thinkers, who
just do your best when
you feel like at least--
- Exactly.
I think we're good.
[END PLAYBACK]
KERRY MAGRO: So if I leave
you with anything today,
I hope it's truly that
you consider yourself,
what David was saying,
a possibility thinker.
I think in our community today,
one of the biggest things
that I see is that
companies look
at what they can do to help
individuals with disabilities.
But I think we need to change
that mindset, where we're
thinking about what
individuals with disabilities
can do for a company versus
the other side around.
This, I think, and thinking as a
possibility thinker, like David
said, can lead to
amazing, amazing change.
David, now in his
50s, has helped
employ thousands and
thousands of individuals
with disabilities simply by
growing up with a disability
and knowing that it is one of
the most untapped markets today
in the United States.
So via our Facebook page,
we've had the opportunity
to interview people with
autism, cerebral palsy,
down syndrome, ADHD,
but also people
who have been impacted by
disease, such as David,
to share their stories
with the world.
It's given us the opportunity
to have these videos seen
over 30 million times.
And we actually
download the videos
for organizations, both business
organizations and also schools,
as educational videos
and resources for them,
for individuals who
simply just want
to learn from the
perspectives of those
impacted by a diagnosis.
So one of the big
initiatives that we do
is during a month
in October, which
has been proclaimed from
the Department of Labor
as National Disability
Employment Awareness Month.
This is also National
Disability Awareness Month,
where we truly highlight
this untapped potential.
We highlight stories of
people impacted by diagnosis
who are succeeding in
the workforce today,
but then we also highlight the
people who are not necessarily
having a good time trying to
find employment, like the boy
I mentioned at the beginning
of my presentation.
So in addition to the
videos we highlight,
I also share my own personal
perspective growing up
with autism in very
quick educational videos,
which I share with employers
throughout the month of October
to encourage employment of
those with disabilities.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Every month in October,
the United States Department
of Labor hosts National
Disability Employment Awareness
Month, an annual
awareness campaign
that looks to
celebrate and educate
about disability employment.
I'm asking you today to
consider supporting the cause,
hosting events in your
workplace around the month,
and, if you haven't
already, look
to employ those with
disabilities in your workplace.
The idea behind NDEAM,
as they like to call it,
goes back to 1945 when
Congress passed a law
saying that the
first week in October
would be National Employed but
Physically Handicapped Week.
Today almost one
in five Americans
has a disability in
the United States,
showing the incredible impact
a month like this can have.
I have a personal connection
to the disability community
in autism.
I was completely non-verbal till
2 and 1/2 years old, diagnosed
with autism when I was four.
And today, as an adult, after
years of supports and therapies
have been able to
hold down five jobs
as a professional speaker,
bestselling author, film
consultant, local TV talk show
host, and nonprofit founder
that mentors and
gives out scholarships
for students with autism and
disabilities to go to college.
I now give talks to
companies about disabilities
in the workforce to educate
about the unique abilities
individuals with
disabilities can have,
if given the opportunity.
I see a future where my
high school mentees, who
all have autism and are
extremely bright and gifted,
can transition to adulthood
and succeed in the workforce.
Some of them may have challenges
at first, but so does everyone.
With the accommodations
in place,
you may very well be surprised
by what you see from each
and every single one of them.
To conclude, US Secretary
of Labor, Alexander Acosta
has said Americans
of all abilities
must have access
to good, safe jobs.
Smart employers know that.
Including different
perspectives in problem
solving situations leads
to better solutions.
Hiring employees with
diverse abilities
strengthens their business,
increases competition,
and drives innovation.
Dr. Temple Grandin reminds us to
see the person, not the label.
Together, let's focus
on making inclusion
celebrated, not only in the
workplace, but in every place
around the world.
[END PLAYBACK]
KERRY MAGRO: So this initiative
truly started a few years
after we started speaking.
Most of the talks
we gave early on we
were talking to
employers about the power
of effective communication
to really spearhead
your organizations, both from
internal perspective and also
an external perspective.
So now today we've
kind of molded that
into presentations going
into not only giving
lunch-and-learn type
of events, but also
going into human
resource departments
and giving consultations
about topics
such as the interview process
for those with disabilities.
Now, just by a show of
hands really quickly,
who in here has met someone in
the past who maybe they didn't
necessarily think
deserved the job
but had a really, really
good interview at the time?
Anyone?
Yeah, it's happened.
It's happened.
Now, many individuals
with I know
with disabilities,
especially individuals who
have communication difficulties,
social difficulties,
don't necessarily see
the interview process as
fair because a lot of the times
these people think concretely.
They think that,
literally, these questions
have to be as concrete
as humanly possible.
So we actually go into
many organizations
and ask about foregoing
the interview process
for a one-day job trial where
potential employees can just
truly show what they're
capable of, especially
in the fields of STEM.
So for many individuals
with disabilities
have really been able to
maximize science, technology,
engineering, and
mathematics jobs
where it's more focused
on one-on-one job
responsibilities versus
an actual group process.
So providing job
descriptions, we also
go into companies
and talk about,
whenever they're putting out a
job application, whether it's
on monster.com LinkedIn,
et cetera and so forth,
that they try to be as concrete
as possible and not vague
in nature.
I mean, we've all had the
application once or twice
where it says, you have to
have good interpersonal skills.
And we're like, OK,
what does that mean?
So it's important to be as
concrete as humanly possible.
And then also talking about
reasonable accommodations,
and the accommodations that
are available for individuals
with disabilities in
the workplace today.
But also showing 503 compliance.
So reasonable
accommodations today--
we believe disclosure
is so, so important.
We truly believe through
the philosophy of just,
as I mentioned in
the video, Dr. Temple
Grandin, who is an amazing,
amazing autism advocate.
One of her biggest quotes is
"see the able, not the label."
And we truly believe
that disclosure
is so important for these kids
who are growing and getting
jobs today to be able
to actually succeed
in the workforce.
So it's against the
law to ask someone
if they have a disability.
And providing awareness events,
not only during October, which
is National Disability
Employment Awareness
Month, but also embracing
diversity all year round
truly, truly helps connectivity
amongst actual workers
in the workplace.
And human resources should
try to be acknowledging
more and more to not only
individuals with disabilities,
but non-disabled individuals
who work at companies
about individuals
with disabilities
and some of the signs
that they may have.
Reasonable accommodations
go further,
taking on a bigger role
with more individuals
later in life developing
physical disabilities.
Not only individuals
who are getting
diagnosed with disabilities
a very early age,
but as people get
older, developing
physical disabilities
is very, very common.
So more awareness
is needed focused
on the lifespan of
disabilities, not only
for individuals who are young,
but also individuals as they
are going into later adulthood.
So my journey with
autism employment-- now,
I was told by--
I was told by
countless people when
I was in school that it would
be very, very hard for me to get
a job one day because I would
think very, very literally.
Sarcasm would go over my head.
I wouldn't understand
any single joke,
and I didn't make my first
friend until I was 14.
So they thought my interpersonal
skills would never give me
the opportunity to
really become someone who
could succeed in the workforce.
And it was a lot
of trial and error.
My parents became my
greatest advocates
growing up, truly getting
me through situations where
we would do mock interviews,
where we would truly
try to help assess and
transition me to the workforce
by giving me
schedules and trying
to help me understand what
the job environment looked
like before I even went
into that specific job.
And I think that's something
that could help anyone, truly.
This gave us the
opportunity to give two TED
Talks in the past five years.
The first talk in my local
community in New Jersey,
The Will of Opportunity--
the Path of Autism
to College, which focuses
on those individuals who
have autism pursuing a
post-secondary education,
but then also finding internship
opportunities in the workforce.
And then the second one, What
Happens to Children with Autism
When They Become Adults,
focuses on a question
that hits a lot of families,
especially parents.
And that is, what will happen
to my child when I'm gone?
In our community today,
especially in the autism
community, over 500,000
individuals with autism
will be reaching adulthood
within the next decade.
Untapped potential,
untapped market
of individuals who
will be reaching
adulthood, and many
of these individuals
will be highly skilled.
Some of the kids
I know with autism
are the brightest
kids in the world.
And my friend
Temple Grandin once
said that she believes
that half of Silicon Valley
is actually on the
autism spectrum
because they think
literally, they're
able to do one-on-one
projects so simply,
and they're some of the most
brightest people you would ever
meet.
So that just goes
into another quote,
which I share a lot of time.
It's that when we're
thinking about the how
to get these individuals
hired, it's best to think of it
as this quote right
here, which says,
"If you've met one
individual with a disability,
you've truly met one
individual with a disability,"
regardless of its autism or not.
There's no one size fits all
for a proper way of hiring
someone with a disability.
So it's truly important to
create your own blueprint
of what that looks like
by simply getting to know
and establishing a rapport with
the individuals you work with.
That can mean
anything from having
more social outings
after work for people
to get to know
each other better,
from peer mentoring programs,
for actual summits where
individuals can have more
opportunities to network
with each other.
But also at the same time,
one of the biggest things
we talk about in a [INAUDIBLE]
basis, the importance
of self-reflection.
And actually, we
encourage many employees,
both with disabilities and
not, to have journal entries,
to continue to self reflect on
their strengths and weaknesses.
Because, especially in
our disability community,
one of my favorite quotes
from Temple Grandin
is "interests and talents
can truly turn into careers."
But for many individuals
with disabilities,
they may not necessarily
think about their strengths
a lot of times
because they're so
focused on trying to overcome
some of the weaknesses
to find a job.
So seven ways I truly
found employment today,
the number one was honing
in on my key interests,
which I'll talk a little bit
later in this presentation.
Becoming a
self-advocate-- when I
was going to college
for the first time,
so in school, individuals
with disabilities
can get an IEP, which is the
Individual Education Plan.
And when I was
going to college, I
received no transitional
services in high school,
so I actually went up to my
post-secondary disability
support specialist
and I told her,
if you could just hook
me up with my IEP,
I'll be out of here and
I'll be ready to go.
And she said, child,
sit down, and told me
for the first time about
reasonable accommodations.
And I never, never
knew about it.
So I had to become
a self advocate.
And I was very
deer-in-headlights at the time.
However, I took it in stride.
I took less credits to
really understand the need
to become a self advocate.
And having that impact at a very
early age in college actually
helped propel me to finding jobs
once I graduated from college.
Asking questions is
another big thing, I think.
And it may seem cliche, but
we still, as a community,
sometimes don't
ask some questions
because we think they're
going to be dumb questions.
And there is no such
thing as a dumb question.
Really make sure that
you're focused on that.
So doing research on job careers
is also very, very important.
Realizing I couldn't
live by a label,
self-reflection
exercises were critical.
I've been writing
in a journal since I
was 12 years old about my
strengths and weaknesses.
When I found out I had
autism at 11 and 1/2,
we were playing celebrity
disability bingo
in one of my social
skills classes,
and I was learning that people
like Michael Jordan had ADD.
Magic Johnson had ADHD.
And I asked, why am I special,
to my social skills teacher.
And she's like, oh, you
have to talk to your parents
about that.
And after school, that was
the first time they told me
I had autism.
But after that, I started
writing journal entries
based on just going
into IEP meetings
to learn about my
strengths and weaknesses.
And then, finally, role
playing different situations,
such as mock interview
processes, truly helped me.
So the two interests that
helped me growing up--
first was theater.
I wanted to be the sixth
member of the Backstreet Boys
growing up.
For my 11th birthday I
wanted the white suit
from the "I Want
It That Way" video.
So I was clearly a dork.
I still am a dork a little bit.
But I fell in love
with music therapy.
At a time when I was
having difficulties
with loud noises,
bright lights, there
was always something
soothing about being onstage,
even though the lights
were there, but also
something soothing about music.
So I stuck to theater
for about 15 years,
and once I graduated
from high school
I became an autism
advocate and found
one of my first jobs,
which was to be an autism
consultant on major
motion pictures
based on my focus on the
entertainment industry,
getting to work on films
such as "Joyful Noise," which
stars a teenager with
autism in the film.
Other films such as
"Jane Wants a Boyfriend,"
which focuses on
a girl with autism
trying to find love
in New York City,
and then also consulting on
documentaries such as "Big
Daddy Autism," which
looks at a single dad
with a nonverbal
child on the spectrum.
And "Don't Foil My Plans,"
which goes into the employment
background, actually
focuses on employment
for those with disabilities.
And then basketball-- I want
to be the next Larry Bird.
So I integrated basketball
into my physical therapy.
Growing up I could
tell you all 30 NBA
teams and every single
player on those teams,
simply because it was
one of my key interests.
And once I graduated
from high school,
I didn't get any Division
I offers-- womp, womp.
But I got involved
with NBA Cares, which
is a nonprofit
organization, getting
to interview countless
NBA celebrities
to share the impact sports
can have on individuals
with disabilities,
and asking them
to consider getting involved
with philanthropic causes
towards our special
need community.
So hiring people with autism
and other disabilities
truly just makes
good business sense.
Customers with disabilities
and their families,
for those in this
room who don't know,
represent a trillion
dollar market today
in the United States.
They, like other
market segments,
purchase products and
services from companies
that best meet their needs.
And a large number
of Americans today
say that they would prefer
to patronize businesses that
hire people with disabilities.
And then, finally, businesses
across the United States
have begun to realize that
hiring talented candidates
with disabilities is not
only the right thing to do,
it makes good business
sense while demonstrating
high return on investment
and aids in 503 compliance,
which every
organization has to do.
So how to manage employees
with disabilities?
This is actually one of the
biggest questions we usually
get during a Q&A period.
And one of the biggest
things, don't come in
with any unperceived notions.
We say that sometimes
we think in a box,
and you have to think
outside the box as well.
Document challenges and
strengths in the workplace.
Please use concrete language
as much as you possibly can.
And take your time when you're
talking to these individuals
and make sure that they
know what you said.
And if they ask
you to repeat it,
sometimes that's going to
be what you have to do.
Make sure all team building
events are accessible.
This is huge.
I've seen so many convocations
where events have happened
with things such as no
wheelchair accessibility,
and it literally blows
my mind to this day.
I would also definitely look
at a leadership book called
"The New One Minute Manager."
it's a fantastic,
fantastic book that
really looks at how you
can go about establishing
a rapport with your employees.
And offer professional
development training
by bringing in experts
and individuals
with disabilities
who have successfully
navigated the workplace.
These are some examples of
success stories of corporations
today who are currently hiring
individuals with disabilities.
One of the common themes you'll
see in many of these companies
is that they have a high
focus on technology,
the SAPs of the world, the
Freddie Macs of the world.
So there is a focus
on those STEM jobs
that are really helping
these individuals.
So finally, I just want to share
with you some quotes from some
of my mentees on what
disabilities and trying to find
employment means to them.
So one individual,
Ron Sandinson,
he's one of the first
pastors to ever have autism.
And he want people to know,
"Employers, we with autism
would love for you to understand
that not all disabilities are
visible.
When we don't look
you in the eye,
it does not mean
we aren't there.
If we fail to shake
your hand or we
say something not
appropriate, it does not
mean we're trying to be rude.
When we need extra
clarification to do the job,
it does not mean we
are slow or stupid.
Due to autism, we process
information differently,
but we also have amazing gifts
like attention to details
and faithful to attended work."
And then I love this guy.
Matthew, who's aspiring
accountant, he says,
"When working with
people with autism,
it's best not to focus
on how they appear.
I feel it is more
important to focus
on their work and the
outcomes of that work.
Even if they look
uninterested and unfocused,
they probably are
interested and focused.
They likely care more
than they let on.
And to quote the 'Transformer'
movie, which he absolutely
loves, there is 'more
than meets the eye'
for individuals with autism."
So finally, what employers
need to focus on today
is clear job responsibilities
more than anything else.
If you go to the Department
of Labor's website,
they have an amazing,
amazing booklet
called "The Business
Strategies that
Work-- a Framework for
Disability Inclusion."
The link is right here.
I'd highly recommend
for anyone who's
looking to hire more
individuals with disabilities
in their workplace to give
it a very thorough look.
It has some guidelines
on everything
we're talking today
about job descriptions,
to how you can host
diversity events
in your workplace towards
individuals with disabilities.
And I've seen it help countless,
countless companies today.
So just as a final thought, I
never thought that any of this
was going to be possible.
When I was growing
up, people told me
that it would be very, very
unlikely that I would even
get to college.
And now the thing I can say
is that even though it's
a spectrum, disability
is a spectrum,
and some kids are going to be on
the severe end, who might need
lifetime care, I
can truly say today
that we as a community
in the United States
are the most diverse in
our history right now.
And we need to think about ways
we can think outside of the box
towards maximizing the potential
of all of our companies.
And with that, I couldn't
think of a better way
than trying to maximize and
utilize the potential of some
of these amazing,
amazing individuals
with disabilities, as long as
we just give them the chance
to show what they're made of.
Thank you all so much
for having me today.
[APPLAUSE]
And at this time, we left a
few minutes left in the program
for Q&A. So we'd be more than
happy to answer any questions
you have at this time.
Thank you all so
much for coming out.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I'm curious,
what specific reasonable
accommodations tend to be
most useful for employees
with autism?
And to what extent do they
have success in getting them?
KERRY MAGRO: So most
of the time they do.
Again, most individuals who file
for reasonable accommodations,
accommodations can be anything
from written explanations
to specific tasks
for specific projects
that they're supposed to do.
Lots of people with autism
think in many different ways.
Some people think in pictures.
Some people think visually.
Some people think in auditory.
So sometimes they
will give things
such as written explanations
on all of their projects.
Sometimes they could
ask for accommodation
where they could get e-mails
versus actually having
to hear a verbal
project, and kind of just
have a breakdown with either
their current boss or someone
who was part of a human
resource department.
That's usually what
we see the most.
But then we also
see accommodations
such as being able to bring a
recorder for some team meetings
to actually be able to--
a confidential
recorder-- to actually
be able to listen to the actual
assignments that they're given,
and also to provide it for
feedback for them as well.
So those are the
two biggest ones
that are currently helping
individuals in the workplace
today that we recommend.
Hope that helped.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The notion of
clear job responsibilities
is very interesting.
We've-- well, thinking about
performance evaluation for some
reason, as well as hiring,
I found that it's difficult
for companies to phrase their
job requirements in that
concrete terms.
So any hints on how
we can do that better?
KERRY MAGRO: So one
of the biggest things
is when someone actually
does apply for a job,
it is a process.
And one of the biggest things
I say, it's not a sprint.
Most of the time it is
very much a marathon
when it comes to each
unique individual who
may be applying for this job.
One of the biggest
things I would truly say
is to really think about--
we try to think of this
as an annual perspective.
So we think about
the job projects
that an individual might
have for out the year,
and we try to talk to companies
about how we can kind of just
pinpoint some specific areas.
So for example, one of
the things that we'll do
is we'll talk to
a human resource
department about
if, for example,
they're in the technology
field and they have
to do a certain amount
of code or they have
to do JavaScript and
focus on a website,
we kind of say, we need
to have HTML in here.
We need to have
JavaScript in here.
So we kind of try
to make it not only
concrete, but as descriptive
as humanly possible.
Many job applications
today are only one page,
which we see on a lot of sites
like monster.com and LinkedIn.
So we try to make sure that
it's not only concrete,
but its also as descriptive
as humanly possible
because those are two
different channels completely.
So it's not only
about being concrete,
but it's also making
sure that you list out
every single
requirement that you're
going to need for that person
as well, especially if they're
doing a very specific
job that is already
going to need proper training
before they go into the job.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
KERRY MAGRO: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
KERRY MAGRO: Glad to be here.
AUDIENCE: I am an
intern recruiter here.
And I've worked with several
candidates who have autism.
Happy to say that many of them
will be joining us this summer
as engineers, which is awesome.
KERRY MAGRO: That's amazing.
Congrats.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I have a question.
I'm just curious if you--
I know you mentioned companies
obviously can't ask people
if they have a disability.
And I think you said that you
advise students, candidates
to self-disclose.
I'm curious what your advice
is like when you tell them
that they should
be self-disclosing,
if it's at the
beginning of the process
or what the timing
of that is like.
KERRY MAGRO: So one of the
biggest things with individuals
with disabilities we see is
that, if you don't disclose
right away, it becomes very,
very difficult once they
actually get into
the workforce to get
those reasonable accommodations
versus actually disclosing
right ahead of time,
because usually there's
a few weeks before an
employer will actually
start the actual
internship or position.
So that gives the human
resource department
a possibility to talk to the
specific boss of that employee
about what some of the
accommodations are going to be.
So if someone, for example, goes
in two, three weeks and says,
you know what?
I need a reasonable
accommodation,
and doesn't, it kind of
brings in a very tough
transitional phase.
And for many individuals
with disabilities,
along with autism, that I
know have very difficult times
at times with
transitions and being
able to go through
that, especially
when you think of many
individuals to this day--
I know adults love things
like visual schedules
and will have these
schedules in either a book
that they bring
around with them where
they have everything set up.
They need to do it right away
to avoid misunderstandings,
miscommunication
at a later time,
especially with transitions,
but also with the communication
with their boss and their team.
So that's the number one reason
why we encourage disclosure
right away.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Makes sense.
Thanks.
KERRY MAGRO: Any other thoughts?
Questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I want to specialize
a little on the issue
of reasonable accommodations.
One thing that I think
tends to get short shrift
is sensory accommodations.
KERRY MAGRO: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So in your
experience, what
have you seen has worked for
people on the autism spectrum
in terms of specifically
sensory accommodations?
KERRY MAGRO: Well,
I know sensory-wise,
so actually in companies
I would always--
and this has
gradually slowed down
as I've gotten a little older.
But I've always used
a sensory brush,
which is like the size
of my palm for whenever
I would have a situation.
Now, I know, obviously, many
reasonable accommodation
in the workplace,
they don't necessarily
provide a sensory brush.
But things-- for example,
I've seen a lot of individuals
with sensory issues
prefer to use
laptops for all
their assignments
versus any written projects,
which is very accessible now
because we're trying to go green
in many companies today anyway.
So utilizing assistive
technology, laptops,
especially for
more sensory issues
that are focused on
just holding things
such as pencils and pens.
There might be textural
issues that individuals
might deal with,
especially if they're
provided in certain ways,
like having to write on paper,
having to write even on a
white board or a smart board
it might be difficult for them.
So being able to utilize
their assistive technology,
whether it be an iPad or being
able to use a computer as well.
So that's one of the bigger
reasonable accommodations
we see, especially
on the sensory realm.
And it's going to vary for
person to person as well.
Hope that helps.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm just
wondering if individual
doesn't self-disclose,
is it polite
and advised to ask if you
think, OK, maybe if I knew that.
What are the better ways to
communicate, for example?
Like whether verbal
communication or written
communication should be used.
What's the best
way to approach it?
KERRY MAGRO: Well
the thing we see
the most is that when companies
do decide to get involved
with professional
training and then decide
to get involved with really
trying to show diversity
in their workplace, it becomes
a more enlightening organization
to have that aha moment where
they're like, you know what?
Maybe we can disclose a
disability, versus a company
where they don't necessarily see
those specific accommodations.
I've gone into many
companies where even
being able to be
wheelchair accessible
and being able to have very
visual signs of that has even
actually come off
to a domino effect
for individuals with
learning disabilities,
saying that they're
doing so much
for physical disabilities that
could trickle down for those
with learning
disabilities and are more
likely to want to disclose.
So it's not only
the visuals that
are around each and
every specific company,
but it's also hosting
special events
and professional training
to focus on diversity
inclusion in the workplace.
AUDIENCE: So my example
is, for example, I
was working an
individual, which appear
to like not paying attention
to what we were doing.
And later I learned
that the individual
was on autism spectrum.
And had I known that,
maybe I tried harder
or tried different
ways of communicating.
So is it something
that's reasonable to ask
directly or not?
KERRY MAGRO: No.
Unfortunately, not.
It's because you have to
think about the individual
in that case and
what their reaction
might be if that is brought up.
And that could lead to
problems down the line
with work effectiveness
and human resource
violation or difficulty
down the line as well.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Thanks for coming in.
My wife and I are
actually in the process
of adopting a child
with special needs,
so this is true and
dear to my heart.
KERRY MAGRO: That's awesome.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
We just finished rounds
of performance reviews.
And I'm curious to hear
what have you consulted
various different
companies on how
to provide effective feedback
for those who have autism
in knowing their condition and
how to address and help them
to grow?
KERRY MAGRO: Sure.
So a perfect example--
so the companies we've spoken
to so far, and the bigger
companies-- we've gone to many
small parent-run organizations.
But we've been to PNC, American
Express, JP Morgan Chase, PSEG,
Wyndham Worldwide.
So we've even done
hotels and how
to be friendlier to hotel guests
who might have individuals
with disabilities.
So one of the biggest
things we kind of talk about
in that realm, about
trying to having
that communication
and that feedback,
is to truly kind of assess
short- and long-term goals
with all individuals.
And this is not only for
individuals with disabilities,
but we should be doing more
one-on-ones, whether it
be on a weekly basis,
a bi-weekly basis,
and trying to assess,
especially to disclose, just
how their process is
going in a specific job
and not necessarily
focus like, so Kerry,
how are you doing as a person
with autism at this job?
Just being just
one-on-one with them
about if their
accommodations-- if they
need more accommodations
once they've
actually disclosed that.
I think that's one of the
biggest, biggest things.
We need more communication
and open communication
because a lot of these
people also think literally.
They also don't
necessarily understand
things such as different
tones of voice,
different tones of
language, and especially
when it comes to body
language and being
able to understand facial
expressions and facial cues
as well.
So the more literal, the better.
And I heard that was
my last question.
I hope that helps.
But I have business cards
for every single person
in this room.
We expect to have
about 100 so I'm
more than happy to
ask any question
and after this presentation.
I thank you all so
much for having me.
It was wonderful.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.